[Music]
all right what's up guys we are getting
exotic romantic expensive today we are
making truffle pasta with mushroom and
spinach it is my take on something that
we experienced in Istria Tiffin I this
past summer went to Austria for a
vacation and we absolutely fell in love
with truffles now Istria is known for
their truffles it's a delicacy that they
export to all over the world and we had
the privilege of going on in a truffle
hunt with the proton family of proton to
our two feet and as a parting gift they
gave us truffle oil then gave us a black
truffle blend a white truffle blend and
a whole bunch of other truffle stuff and
since coming back I've been savoring all
of it it's just so good so before TIFF
gets home from work I am going to show
you guys how I make my version of
truffle pasta with mushroom and spinach
all right so this dish is very very easy
to make it only requires a few basic
ingredients
we're in started off with one
medium-sized white onion we're gonna
dice it up as well as three to four
cloves of garlic you move and I set it
up as well and we also have a bowl of
mushrooms
we got crimini moister shiitake baby
bella and I like using all these
different mushrooms because of the
different textures and subtle flavors
that they provide all right so now that
we have everything prepped we're gonna
fire up the stove and we're gonna toss
in half a tablespoon of butter and let
that melt
next we add in our chuckle and about two
tablespoons shout-out to proton Tartuffe
II for hooking us up
next we're gonna toss in the onions and
we're gonna sweat the flavors out just
caramelize the onions and once we have
that caramelize we're gonna toss in the
garlic and we're gonna saute that for a
few seconds and then we're gonna work in
our mushrooms stir in the mushrooms and
let the mushrooms soak up all that
flavor a truffle the garlic the onion
[Music]
next I'm gonna add in another truffle
product this is a white truffle cream
courtesy of proton Tartuffe II it's made
up of the minced white truffle cheese
and olive oil we're going to sport that
in mix it up and at this point you can
really smell the umami in the air I mean
it's filling the kitchen up
all right so today I'm gonna modify my
recipe a little bit for the video I'm
gonna introduce a little bit of white
wine and hopefully the wine can add a
little bit of sweetness to my sauce and
that's about 8 ounces of white wine and
then add 8 ounces of heavy cream now
like I said before the wine is a new
addition for me so normally I do 16
ounces of cream so it's all cream no
wine today I'm splitting it
half-and-half eight ounces eight ounces
of each add salt to taste cook it for
another three to five minutes and reduce
it to a thicker consistency okay that
everything in slow motion looks way more
delicious all right and off to the side
we have a pot of farfalle pasta boiling
I chose farfalle because my wife loves
for folly and we're gonna drain and add
our pasta into the sauce and we're gonna
work those two in together and make sure
not to stir it in but to fold it in
gently
next we're gonna add some Parmesan
cheese to help us thicken the sauce and
to add a little more complexity to the
flavor profile turn down the heat and
we're gonna use residual heat now to
review the rest of the work for us
we're gonna add in two handfuls of
spinach and fold it in into the pasta
work it through the sauce and let that
residual heat gently cook that spinach
for us so if you want to go vegetarian
this is where you stop but if you happen
to be a carnivore like me plus there on
some steak now this is not a steak video
so this is the basic salt and pepper
steak cooked a medium perfection
[Music]
I made this posture for Valentine's and
let me tell you
Tiff's eyes lit up the moment she took a
bite so for all the guys out there
trying to impress a special someone try
this one out it's me I'm so excited you
made this again I've been dreaming about
this classic did you tell them that you
made a move of course for Valentine's
yeah I was telling them that how I was
craving you're waiting okay you go ahead
go ahead
well you know what first I'm like
panicking all right I made this
humungous plate for you first but then I
also know that you like European sizes
in terms of like portions so this is
kind of a big stat American size is it
it's pretty you're peeling that's just a
small play European portion this is a
huge plate the food shouldn't cover the
entire plate it's not appetizing to me
and was it covered in our place is a
restaurant portion in fancy place
that's a portion at like Olive Garden
true it would actually fill up like way
more I think probably and the plates
gonna be bigger too yeah yeah huge all
right you want to go Olive Garden or you
want to go European I'll keep it fancy
and then if I want more I'll just throw
in some more taste test
Ruby do you remember this do you
remember this pasta delicious
[Applause]
[Music]
it's different
yeah modified it a little bit for better
for worse for worse okay well Emily wait
works it's still really really good but
it just tastes like the watered-down
version of what you made last time I
added wine you don't like the wine you
want to go all cream mix I'm well I'm
just saying the last time was like
perfection you don't mess with
perfection okay next time we do without
the wine belong cream because that's
what I love I love creamy pasta
I failed guys she didn't give me the
look of love on Valentine's Day I swear
I swear on valentine's they should be
like the love eyes of all time ever why
would you modify it to make it even more
love baby what do you think like you
don't - damn you liked it this bomb is
behind you like it can you taste the
difference between the last one and this
one
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]